en quelques mots monsieur le monsieur le
Président 45 000 forces de l'ordre ont
été mobilisées l'intégralité je l'ai dit
des forces ministères de l'Intérieur à
votre arrivée des services de
renseignement une très bonne
collaboration non seulement avec mystère
de la justice mais avec les procureurs
de la République qui ont su je crois
être au rendez-vous de la travail très
important fait par la police et par la
gendarmerie mais une sociologie qui
interroge la sociologie des délinquants
des émotiers interroges sur ces 3500
interpellations j'ai l'occasion de le
dire la moyenne d'âge entre 17 et 18 ans
elle a tendance à augmenter un tout
petit peu puisque aujourd'hui ce que
nous faisons c'est que nous allons
chercher un interpellation des personnes
qui ont été soit par les travaux
d'enquête technologiques que chacun
comprendra ici récupérer des personnes
un petit peu plus âgées mais le dernier
comptage que j'avais c'est que la
dernière la première personne qui a été
interpellée à 11 ans et la dernière à 59
ans et que si il y a une moyenne de 17 à
18 ans pour ceux qu'on a arrêté et que
un tiers mineur vous aurez donc compris
que les mineurs que nous avons
interpellés sont extrêmement jeunes pour
la plupart Paul part d'entre eux comme
j'ai dit aux questions gouvernement
monsieur le Président nous pouvons
constater par ailleurs que à notre
connaissance seule 10% des personnes que
nous avons interpellées sur de
nationalités non françaises et
d'ailleurs il y a eu 40 placements en
centre de rétention administratif ce qui
est peu à vous le sur 3500 personnes
interpellées je voudrais aussi souligner
que comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure à ma
connaissance 60% des personnes que nous
avons interpellé n'ont pas de casier
judiciaire et ne sont pas connus des
services de police
cette évidemment difficile d'aller plus
au delà de la sociologie de ces
personnes puisque après les
interpellations
ces personnes sont rentrées dans un
fichier qui s'appelle Casio p qui a
affiché judiciaire et il appartient sans
doute à monsieur le garde des sceaux
donnaient des informations dans quelques
jours je crois que c'est un peu trop tôt
pour qu'il puisse le faire sur la
composition exacte des personnes pour
que nous comprenions leur origine
géographique
et des motivations éventuelles qui les
ont amenés à commettre ces